yes sir with the egoraptor face you can
do it for Halloween you could go okay
okay
anywho ricardio played by George Takei
or Takei I don't give it to crap it's
it's nice hearing his voice come on this
very scary heart and okay so you got
this
this heart comes in starts totally
smooth what's the losing smoothing the
princess character which I like to fight
the kept her a scientist that they're
talking about really nerdy scientist
stuff or at least candy SIA well
whatever that world's ideas of that and
comes in Finn things Finn is feeling
jealousy and doesn't know if he's evil
or not and it's not jealous he's just
weird
that's right where does the wavy arm
that you notice the arms are very much
like those things you see it like car
dealerships with the balloon yeah all
the arms are kind of like that hey
somebody should make that they should
make like a fin version of that actually
be really funny burger so uh so Finn is
jealous / suspicious of the ricardio and
follows him was it that ice king is as
Nick yes yeah he he finds him and says
it's my heart I was trying this
experiment and the heart is evil wants
to rip out Bubblegum's heart which is
like really that that's very intense the
one part that had to legitimately
hoecakes or maybe like step away from
the TV is what does this extreme closeup
of the hearts face say I will cut out
her heart and make it my own and it's
just like it's like a legitimately like
creepy scene and they kick the crap out
of the heart I guess and the King puts
it back in and flies off with his beard
always how we flew or is that a new
thing okay uh always does
okay never knows I've I thought that was
pretty funny um and then Princess
Bubblegum almost has been kiss her but
happy ending
so I mean okay it's nice to see Finn
like I said sort of deal with the idea
of jealousy you know not really knowing
what it is you know that's kind of fun
and I don't know you can almost argue
some very interesting metaphor about
like the heart leaving the body and like
controlling everything but I probably
think about too hard honestly so yeah
trapping what else I said though the one
joke the one joke I thought would have
been a little funny you're looking at
there's a scene where the hearts gonna
take out Bubblegum's heart he's got her
tied up and I thought would that be
funny if I don't know how they go up
with the ropes stop in a heart shape
like around her heart I thought that'd
be play cuz he's gotta cut it out cuz it
was wrong so yeah it's like wait how
would you do there without anything the
ropes I thought that might have a look
cute but I think that's the one joke
ever I said you know this show really
showed done this job so I think that's
impressive for like what five six
episodes and being like you don't they
missed an opportunity so yeah it was my
it was great hearing George Takei do
that voice and also it was interesting
cuz his voice this time around like you
know when he talks he almost does an
impression of himself and here he did
that too but it seemed a little bit more
natural as well like when you would talk
I almost went recognize his yeah
sometimes cuz it seemed like he was just
talking normally which was kind of cool
to hear um for me I loved the fact cuz
it always drives me nuts that what does
what phrase does he always rely on it's
his catchphrase now well which one whom
uh yeah that's right and I did it what
nope no no no that's that's really kind
of cool that they didn't rely on that
they actually just relied on him himself
yeah so I thought that was cool it's
ricardio a natural name or did they make
that is ass cuz I'm thinking like that
sounds weird I'm thinking Ricardo I'm
like it's like a mix between Ricardo and
cardio right is that what yeah
I don't think so I don't think so I
could be wrong though apparently I
didn't know Finn was a real name so how
could you not know Finn is a real do you
know no Irish people know and I am Irish
okay Finn again Finlay if there's like a
bajillion oh my okay okay your your
favorite shows like Adventure day you
didn't know Finn was a real Knight no
honestly I did not why am i having you
along with this if you didn't even know
Finn was a real name because I'm more
into the show than I am into reality
fair enough okay with that said any
other stuff you have on this episode and
anything that really comes to mind no I
think you hit it on the head with the
whole thing having to deal with jealousy
where he doesn't realize what jealousy
is or he does and he just doesn't want
to admit that he's actually jealous of
what's going on so we'd rather just be
like no he's evil or I'm the strange I
like how it's the whole really
twelve-year-old dealing with that same
situation yeah I won't liked it maybe I
liked playing around with the idea is he
evil is he not you know he beats up and
at first he looks evil but then he beats
up the Ice King oh maybe he's good but
that turns out he is evil a little I
think did that maybe a few more times
like maybe up till like the very end
you're still getting like he always has
a reason for it as well like to take
your heart no no it's all part of this
experiment I'm doing no no it's a serum
I gave her to always tell a lie the part
of an experiment we were doing is I mean
it's like if they could console II keep
juggling that that'd be even a little
funnier but thinking we probably get
that relief screen close-up scary shot
that's very very I'm just gonna have
that do you like I'm just gonna like one
thing I'm just gonna go like Rob's house
in like camp I'd be like the screensaver
he just comes in sees his computer just
with that big face up I'll do you have
to scare the out of him so but yeah
just basic fun episode you know get
can't fake it too much else to say about
it um I guess I do like that does go to
kind of those like I said a lot of stuff
I would be like wow how like this is
getting past sensors and
ee the idea of cutting out her heart
yeah and making out with it I like that
um you know it's just the idea of doing
that like that gets pretty grisly but I
think because they don't show it or do
it it's kind of okay I mean we hear
worst stuff talked about like in Disney
films like oh yeah let's know why he's
got like the heart of a pig you know and
stuff inside there's some grisly stuff
but I like they don't necessarily shy
away from it and they still keep it in
good humor too like if you just I'm
gonna cut out her heart does that be
really grisly but the fact that he says
you know and make out with it actually
it makes it more krisily but we have the
idea like you think they'll have eyes in
a face and stuff yeah so they do a
really good balance of the twisted and
demented with the whole we're gonna toss
in a little joke before or afterwards to
kind of soften the blow and make it like
oh okay so it's not so nasty yeah it's
very it is sort of fun balance of really
intensely like gross and disgusting and
violent and really cutesy in to send out
fun it's it is kind of funny balance
yeah um it does a pretty good Angela
even Finn can be and I like shows that
do that like shows I can have that
balance like even Finn can be very you
know he can swing a sword around to be
really extremely confront your uh but
then he can like hold a little jiggler
and be like you know Joe I'm kissing it
I don't know what else to do it's like
that's so disgustingly innocent yeah you
know and it'll have a lot of moments
like that so it does kind of balance out
and I think I think that is kind of fun
um I like that more shows are at least
dabbling with that I think amount of
time this comes out the Oh what episode
is that the sharknado episode will come
out wait we talked about it how we're
sort of like you know because we try to
come over an idea of like this these
extreme masculine titles but then we
found they're all taken by sci-fi so we
go for these extreme feminine titles but
then we find that actually the biggest
market is both extreme masculine and
extreme feminine so we so really cutesy
nice and is it with really violent gory
testosterone stuff and mash them
together and that actually seems to be
very in right now and I know I think
it's kind of cool I think it's cool that
like this mix mash mishmash is going on
so yeah decent episode we'll see in
next one